ALBERT MEYER: The topic
for this video lecture
is Connected Vertices,
the kind of connections
we can have between different
vertices through edges.
We're going to start by
showing that the shortest walk
between two vertices is a path.
We're going to prove
it by contradiction.
Suppose we have some
path from u to v
and it crosses over itself.
So here we have u and v. At
some point, you get to c,
and you go back to c, and
from there you go to v.
So you've gone through
some vertice twice.
But if you want to get
the shortest path from u
to v, why would you
go through this loop?
Why not just keep going
straight from c to v?
The path without that section
that goes from c back to itself
also for u to v and is shorter.
So if we have any path
that crosses over itself,
we can just get rid of
that part that loops around
back into itself, and we
still have a walk from u to v.
So therefore the
shortest walk from u to v
is going to be a path.
Now we're going to talk
about the length and the walk
relation.
What this means is with
two vertices, v and w,
there is this Gn
relation between v and w
if there exists a length
n walk from v to w.
Gn is called the length
n walk relation for G.
So basically, if
you can find a way
to go from v to w in
exactly n steps, then
Gn applies from v to w.
G itself, when you think
about it, is a length 1
walk relation.
The graphs define
these relations.
There is an edge from
one vertice to another
if there is a length 1 edge
from one vertice to another.
It is itself.
Now, this lemma-- they say that
Gm and relational composition
with Gn equals Gm plus n.
Let's explain with this means.
So what that relational
composition means
is that the relational
composition between the two
applies from x to y if
there is some vertice,
z, such that there is
a path, n, from x to z,
and then a path, n, from z to y.
Gm applies from x to z and
Gn applies from z to y.
And this is why this is the same
thing as Gm plus n makes sense.
If there is a path length
n to z and a path length
n from there to y, you just
go from x to z in m steps,
then z to y in n steps.
And you have m plus
n steps from x to y.
The length 0 walk
relation just make
each vertice go back to itself.
It points back to itself,
the individual one.
And the lemma is still true.
G0 composes with Gn is
just Gn, which makes sense.
Everything itself plus
Gn just gives you Gn.
Let's talk about
composition of matrices.
So if we have some
adjacency matrix for G
and we do a
composition with sum h,
then we can get that by applying
this Boolean and/or matrix
multiplication.
These adjacency matrices
are ones and zeros.
So we do matrix multiplication,
but with Boolean operations
instead of plusses
and multiplications.
So we can compute A G of n by
fast matrix exponentiation.
How do we do that?
Well, basically you can do
it for G n over 2 twice,
and then Gn over f
for each of those
twice, and go doing those
Boolean operations on each.
So A G of n equals
A G of n over 2,
applying this operator
to A G n over 2.
So you can just break
it down in 2 each time
so you get logarithmic number
of problems that we have to do.
Now let's define
another relation.
G star is just called the
walk relation of G. Basically,
G star applies from u to v
if there is a walk from u
to v, no matter how long it is.
If you can find some way to get
from u to v, then it applies.
If you want to get
the walk relation,
you just get everything inside
the graph and apply self-loops.
So add in an edge that
points back to itself
for every vertice.
We called this G less
than or equal to.
It's basically G and then
add in these G0 self edges.
And G less than or
equal to has a length n
walk if G has a less
than or equal to n walk.
Now, think about that.
If I can get from
vertice x to vertice y
in n minus some
amount of steps in G,
then I can get there in
n steps in G less than
or equal to because I
can just loop around.
If I want to get here
from red to blue,
I can get there in one step
without those self-loops.
But with the self-loops, I can
just keep starting from red
and go around to red as
many times as I want,
n minus 1 times, and
then do this final step.
So I can make a length
n walk for any value
of n greater than 1.
Now let's compute
the walk relation
using what we've just defined.
So G has n vertices.
So the length of paths are going
to be less than or equal to n.
If you just go in a straight
line from one thing to another,
passing through each
possible vertice,
at most you're going to
get n minus one length.
Because you're going to
pass through n vertices,
so there's n minus 1 edge
that's connected there.
So G star, which is
just the relation
if there is a walk from u to v,
is going to be this G less than
or equal to n minus 1.
So if we get G less
than or equal to,
add in all these
self-loops, and then find
all of the paths
of length n minus 1
in there, which is
basically all paths since G
less than equal to n minus 1
is all paths less than or equal
to n minus 1.
But since G only
has paths of less
than or equal to n minus 1,
that's just all the paths.
It's just every single
one of the vertices.
And so we've defined
G star and that's
how we get all
connected vertice pairs.
And we can do this
in n squared log n
time using that composition
of the adjacency matrices.